[Music]
for many people the kovat 19 pandemic is
more than a health crisis the homeless
refugees or single-parent families are
more vulnerable than ever to financial
and social hardship the EU is making it
a priority to ensure those who rely on
others for the most basic needs are not
cut off through national organizations
the fund for European aid to the most
deprived provides food basic necessities
and social support to those in need
lockdown measures have made reaching the
vulnerable more difficult the European
Parliament has backed improvements to
its support system to overcome the
obstacles of social distancing delivery
of food and basic material assistance
will be available through vouchers
distributed by national organizations to
people in need who are not able to use
the usual distribution places due to the
lockdown measures Parliament's made sure
that the vouchers are also available in
paper to be able to reach people who do
not have access to email or other
electronic means so through the Evo Jers
people might get help and this would
protect those one who deliver the ads
Parliament was very urgent clean also
for a paper option not only Evo chairs
because we have huge communities of
people who wouldn't be able to work
through a voter's during the pandemic
the fund will be 100% EU funded covering
the 15% normally contributed by Member
States
Oh